now in this video you might be a little
bit confused why there is a random bird
riding shotgun well this specific bird
is a shear water and it belongs in the
sea not in the middle of the road so our
friend johnny decided to run out of the
car and save it when you're done
watching this video just click that
annotation right there to choose a new
adventure and neutralize it okay so
johnny
just stole a duck he's just a little
duck up on the side of the street it's
not a duck it's a sheer water these are
endangered species what are you gonna do
with them they can't fly they can only
take off from the cliffs dude i almost
hit him can i see it
cover them up we can't participate
hi oh we have a present hey
you guys are so good here let's put them
out of the
wind a little bit
i almost ran it over
okay
face that into all shoots
awesome awesome awesome
he's uh he's just fled that's so rad
you see this before no old shear water
wow
that's so cool so humane society's on
their way and they're gonna pick him up
if he's um if he's strong and the whale
and not dehydrated they'll probably
release them tonight yeah and we have a
release box here but they'll probably
take him take them down south you guys
won't come back to land to nest until
they're like four years old
how old is it no um this is a chick so
it hatched um probably late july early
august
he's so cute
you